the big ones clearly on deck are
healthcare education and financial
services i think are the the next three
kind of giant sectors um where i think
software can have a revolutionary impact
um we're actually been putting we
actually started out saying we're not
going to do any health care it was one
of our things we had a bunch of no fly
zones when we started our firm no rocket
ships uh no no flying cars um
no space elevators um no no drugs either
in the
drug development sense or any other
sense um
uh and then um
and then uh and then we said no no no
biotech no health care um because it's
you know it's a different category and
if you're going to make you know
pharmacists you know invest biotech
companies or medical device companies
fda approval it's a different thing
we've actually gotten much more involved
lately in the cross-section of
healthcare and i.t
and there's all kinds of interesting
things happening at the intersection of
healthcare and nit and software
and actually there's things happening
actually on the medical side and a lot
of that it's very interesting things not
happening around genomics and big data
applied to genomics
and then
there's another whole set of things
happening around healthcare information
and you know making like health
marketplaces work better and you know
direct access for consumers to doctors
online and all these incredible uh kind
of new services so i think healthcare is
going to be really interesting and we're
diving in much more aggressively there
education you know is a big one
that i've talked about a lot in public
but i think education is right for for
transformation actually clay christensen
has been doing really amazing work on
that uh that's what's worth reading um
he's very passionate about that
and then financial services um i mean we
think it's it's go time for financial
services um we needed a breakthrough
software technology to be able to go
after financial services financial
services right the big problem for
startups and financial services is it's
regulated to death um and so um and it's
gotten worse right
we call dodd-frank the big bank
protection act of 2012 like it's it's
the largest wall in the world for a
startup to have to climb over um to
really compete from scratch but bitcoin
and cryptocurrencies give us the
technology change that we needed to go
after financial services um and so we
are now looking at a very broad
cross-section of
new kinds of whether it's new kinds of
lending new kinds of insurance new kinds
of derivatives
new kinds of um you know small business
financing new kinds of fundraising
crowdfunding crowdsourcing
we think now there's enough technology
change happening
and both consumers and businesses are
kind of desperate for alternatives that
there are some very interesting new
financial services companies to get
built
and then the long run the two that we
would like to work on we haven't gotten
to yet but in the long run law and
government are the other two really big
ones